please welcome from Kill Bill uma
thurman and from Cold Mountain
Best Actor nominee Jude Law
the lights go down the film begins and
suddenly you're there the
cinematographer gives us a front row
seat to Worlds we only imagined the
nominees for achievement in
cinematography are says out char Loney
for City of God John feel for cold
mountain
Eduardo's Sarah for girl with a Pearl
Earring Russell Boyd for Master and
Commander the far side of the world and
John Schwartzman for Seabiscuit and the
Oscar goes to
Russell Boyd for Master and Commander
the far side of the world
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for Russell boy
I have an Australian accent I'd like to
thank the Academy and a wonderful cast
and crew if I could mention my entire
coma crew by name I'd be here all night
but they did an absolutely wonderfully
supporting job for me and for Peter for
the whole production also I'd like to
thank Pat Mary my gaffer and Kristen
teller my key grip and mercenary Moorish
and to Duncan Henderson who steered the
ship some of the time he was a great
great person to work with and most of
all to Peter Weir who provided
extraordinary inspiration to all of us
to give our best and my family sandy and
my boys thank you very much
coming up Tobey Maguire Tom truely's
and the awards for best directing an
actress in a leading role the 76th
annual Academy Awards on ABC